he's an American business magnate he
co-founded the hip-hop music label Def
Jam and the clothing line fat farm he's
the third richest figure in the hip-hop
world with a net worth of over three
hundred and forty million dollars he's
Russell Simmons and here are his top 10
rules for success the business plan may
not work out the way you wrote it down
there'll be some deviations there'll be
some roadblocks people start over again
and again and again on new ideas but the
person who stays focused on his idea on
his dream realizes history I've never
had a business that pet that didn't hit
roadblocks every business from my record
business TV show runs house runs house
was turned down ten times and we just
kept pushing fat farm we had we
addressed it over and over and over
again
six years later pal you know Jim good
entrepreneur we find this real service
that people really need and you go to
work and you provide that service and
then you also a person you can see all
kinds of white spaces because people
need everything all people need
everything they're suffering for lack of
almost everything so yeah I get it that
everything is being done is the mindset
the CEO has got quarterly important but
the entrepreneur has got an open mind
and honest intention is always at the
core not usually at the core of a
worldly business success I mean it's I
want to give people something they need
hopefully you're giving something to
need that you approve of you know if
you're vegan don't have a steakhouse you
know something like that but but it's a
idea of going to work and giving people
something that you believe in and and
and make it an honest intention more so
that that you give without you know so
much it's not about the expectation of
receiving so much it does faith in this
idea that if you put your energy into
something
your return but it is something greater
about loving something enough to just
want to share it and I think that that's
a major motivation we all should have if
you want happiness and success what you
want to do in life is be in walking
meditation you want to have you want to
watch be the watcher the Yogi's referred
to it in fact they call it the watcher
for the person in the world but not
connected so therefore not attached so
therefore he can be act with more
thorough thoughtful you know see it so
you can do twice as much in half the
time because you cannot do in the future
you only do now so the idea being awake
and thoughtful and productive comes when
you're present other than that you know
you're thinking about a result the
result doesn't pay you the prayer is the
work itself if you can be here then
that's the prayer being here is the
happy experience being in the future and
getting stuff the result that you prayed
for you missed the presence because you
attach too much to the toy or to the
result and causes sickness and sadness
just like the noise in the outside so
nothing happens except from the inside
out
certainly not happiness and and you want
to operate from abundance some
Christians would say some people say we
operate from abundance so when you're a
present and awake your seat or you want
life is a comfortable seat if you have
that comfortable seat and you need for
nothing needing nothing attracts
everything and needing nothing you're a
good giver and good givers are great
getters the idea of a super-rich idea of
operating from abundance the idea going
out and makes me work your prayer the
idea of building something that no one
else can believe in you can believe in
God gives you this vision he gave it to
you and through a loan you have to carry
a cross for a little bit on your own
people will watch you first they'll
cheer and they'll be upset with you then
they'll get real mad you'd be on the
couch when you get off the couch and you
you do this here oh it's impossible if
God gave me that vision for you to fail
at it unless you quit so this is very
important nothing because in fact in
every business everybody quits all the
time the success stories the ones who
went the extra mile I'd rather the
prosperity preacher he kind of beat me
up about the book is like too much about
giving and didn't really explain you
know enough about getting so I opened up
and I know I wrote a book in two months
but ten months later I came up with a
truth that was not that I'd known but
didn't think of Jesus taught to service
once the masses if you give you're good
giver you're being great get up that's
the answer which is what I just told you
but he taught his disciples just give
and those people never had problem with
the Romans and taxes in Iraq [ __ ]
because they made plenty of money so it
was but this idea of giving you know and
having faith that it will have a return
but not putting too much weight on the
return and in fact unless you put on
that the more your your your cycle of
giving will speed up the more you become
an honest giver they all want to be
awake you can't get no money in the
future or in the past you have to be
present and thoughtful and awake and
clear with great brain functionality
that's what makes you make money right
or success worldly success at least so
my view is that you know presence is is
not not my view I mean for thousands of
years people have told you this all the
prophets all talk about this this
present state of mind this idea be still
and know right it's in every scripture
taught by every everybody over and over
in different languages by different you
know different colors you know different
ages same rap so this idea of presence
or Christ consciousness or Nirvana or
Samadhi or taqwa for Muslims this idea
of the awakened state we all are more or
less in it or moving towards it so the
more present we are the more thoughtful
and awake and aware we are the greater
we can perform a basketball player is
always looking to be in the zone right
when you're in a zone that's like that
awakened state the rim is like a
swimming pool you can't
right it really that's me that's you
right yeah I said you didn't there you
just told me you play basketball so you
know it's like when you get high no no I
read um run there's freedom there's
focus there's awareness there's
consciousness you can make the ball go
into rim when the noise is in the mind
the rim is tiny and you can't get there
mm-hmm so what we want to do is to be
awake so you put the ball in the rim
mm-hmm and and we there's lots of
instances where we have this experience
for those who don't play basketball
you're in a car accident the world moves
slow the present moment takes over the
future and the past are gone
so we meditate as a tool the greatest
tool we have to promote this kind of
consciousness with the Sun full of what
I learned in my book super glue to take
a lot out of a thousand aplenty realize
some basic ideas problem for us behind
fascism very business one one no no it's
critical to me this is notes on this
great Christian yogi say the
imaginations God he also would skip it
hard work dedication and page if you had
enough imagination and a miracle to
happen they say those are like Jesus
would say all those things I do you can
do it even greater
all these this idea that if you had
enough faith things would happen
automatically like most of us man just
normal people we go about our work
dedicate ourselves and keep I hand down
our resilient
usually you stop it idea no one agrees
with on the stand and certainly it's
okay the first day maybe you come home
and tell you life again that's great
go to a library start to research it
it's my play anything coming to fruition
on your feelings vision okay when six
years later like this teasing these
things and it is 7dn becomes comes the
paths and everybody's like Bobby so
small you know and what you were
resilient a lot of mistakes along the
way but you have faith and faith is the
most critical element they said we've
got a lone miracle happening again hard
work dedication kill you critical good
practicing yoga pretty much every day
for 20 years I went things with so many
hot it was crazy with no guys in the
class in it only hot girls in class or
two yes I started going to yoga
regularly after the first class I was
inspired and aside for day
but I find that if you take your time to
meditate if you take time and take care
of your first shot of the self-tan
Mullin dollar they call it take care of
self then everything else can come from
there and if you don't take care of
yourself if you have noise in your head
the seconds of presence aware all the
creativity all our happiness all that
everything comes from those seconds
presence what can we do to extend our
seconds of awareness to be awake this is
what we have to start so I recommend
everyone my kids twice a day meditate
you still let the thoughts settle the
world all on the outside is just a bunch
of sickness annoyed but inside is where
everything comes from anything good that
contributes good to sickness and noise
on the outside has to come from here so
you have to operate from here she's
worried about the rent
okay she's a single mother sure better
care to register you know and then you
could do about the rent worrying about
it I think I'll get you to rent presents
and Happiness gets you rent money can't
make you happy but happy can make you
money so be happy go out in the world
with your story the guy in the shanty
house he rolls over in the morning
meditates goes out in the world say damn
I'm gonna have to get some bread and
water for the whole to go down if I get
back in that bed but the meantime be
nice to all my neighbors in the shanty
village everybody is suffering in what
everyone else calls extreme poverty but
he's happy didn't have a poverty mindset
noise he worry about that bread water
they don't give me some Bob bread I
don't worry about that I'm that dude he
walks out smiling confident comfortable
he gets what he needs he says the
Yogananda would say God will provide but
really your God is working to get and it
will shows up he gets his bread water he
makes everybody happy everybody makes
him happy laid in the bed next [ __ ] he
wakes up he's got it you know you know
36 billion dollars in the bank he gets
up the stock market goes up he says all
I get
kokin some of all get happy so excited
exploding and making more money more
money morning
oh she crashed oh [ __ ] more cocaine more
alcohols in a pop up about his hot gold
up and down uh and he dies at forty the
shanty house guy lives at a hundred to
one hundred the end other guys diet not
to die to the guy took but the other
guys opportunity for a greater diet the
guy in the shanty eyes met were made hun
twenty but you know made a hundred this
guy died at forty that's the reality of
all you know our happiness is up to us
you know our relationship with the world
is up to us our anxiety is controlled or
given to us by us thank you so much for
watching I made this video because
Quintin Scarborough asked me to so if
there's a famous entrepreneur that you
want me to profile next leave it in the
comments below and I'll see what I can
do I would also love to know which of
Russell Simmons top ten rules had the
biggest impact on you leave it in the
comments and I will join in the
discussion thank you so much for
watching continue to believe and I'll
see you soon